try it oh I thought that I could just
bite down on it and shoot through no
there's a there son okay hi I'm Leah I
grew up on Maui Hawaii and spacely like
a fun tropical rock
hi I'm Michelle I grew up in Arcadia
which is about 20 miles east of LA today
I think I'm going to try out some
Hawaiian snacks maybe some that I've
never seen or tasted before
hi my name is Julie and I am a Southern
California native hi guys my name is
Shawn a cockapoo honky Tonk cometa I
know it's long trust me I'm from
Honolulu born and raised one thing I
love about Hawaii so much is it so why
do I just think you have it's a melting
pot of different cultures so you have
like Japanese snacks Korean snacks
Chinese snacks - packs for cheese snacks
and we kind of like just mix mash it
into it like this amazing beautifulness
of like you know said I love it
what you crunch oh my god this this is
like a go-to
for classic check six right here so
California right here so this is caught
okay so there's like five hundred names
so I known this back home and it's a
little uh today or mochi crunch socrata
ah today is because of its shape that's
like the Sakura cherry blossom but you
put this a pop core with some through
the cockade in it oh it's so good
[Music]
I'll take a flavor bomb of like soy
sauce
super crunchy and then if you get the
corners there's like a little bit like
this charge aware I mean I'll get the
pretzel if I have to but I'm not really
a pretzel friend this bread piece
looking wrong I picked this out and
forget about everything else
whoa holy sparklers so this is Hawaiian
Sun this is everywhere in Hawaii let
every grocery store every mama pop store
this juice is really a mouthful of
heaven I haven't had this since I was
maybe in like third grade
and that was only if it was like a good
day and my mom was like you're allowed
to have sugar here you go I don't have
this anymore
it smells a little tart like it could be
not sleep
oh this is really yummy I've never had
kool-aid at a soda this tastes like a
soda so it is it's like carbonated
kool-aid I don't know I don't like it
that I love this I mean it honestly
tastes like a kind of boy boy had oh my
god yes my childhood all of my childhood
things
oh wow warheads is it stuck just throw
back oh my god okay so you know how I
was talking about the leading powder
well this is a leading boy which is
literally the epitome of like Hawaiian
salty sour foods
this is lean Wayne and it's like a seed
with this coating over it I remember
growing up having it at the beginning I
didn't like it and then as I got a
little older I didn't mind it this is
definitely a strong taste it will make
you grow a mustache and some muscles
warehouses is very so I'm kind of scared
is there different flavors oh my gosh
like as soon as you open a bag you can
smell it it smells very tart I love
lemon because it's like lemons already
sour as is but it's like that plus the
wardeness it's like sour times infinity
so try the lemon fresh the lemon flavor
and so let's pop this but is it more
sour than
[Music]
but thanks different from like the dried
plum sour belts which is more like candy
that's like salty I'm kind of bitter you
said this was good right it's like sour
and bitter I'm funky but I'm gonna go in
and try it I thought that I could just
bite down on it I can shoot through no
there's a there's a okay it kind of my
CI what is that so this is Iike which is
shredded soft have you had this is so
good mmm-hmm dry squid this is so good I
remember growing up my mom used to get
these for me all the time I would just
like constantly eat it
finish the bag I have a slim jim I
always think of this is like gas station
anything Slim Jim and beef jerky like
that's my job so I'll gladly switch this
machine have fun with it I am very very
intrigued by this shredded squid
situation smells really weird and thinkI
but let's see
it's an interesting oh my god
the texture is really funky like it's
like rubbery and kind of stringy see I
like these these are just like slim VP
sticks okay
so dried squid is not as dry as you
might think it's actually you can see
like all these like little slight fibers
flaking off which look weird but they're
actually kind of yummy and chewy this
reminds me of something of late that we
call like Portuguese sausage
I don't know wash it off I love hor
jiggies awesome right it tastes like
pork sausage but just like Anna skinnier
skinny form this isn't bad at all only
four grams of four grams of carbs which
I mean I'd imagine pretty keto friendly
right there a Californian oh yes
laughs smack so I said leaking was like
the pinnacle of like Hawaiian like food
snacks this is the pinnacle of wine
losses neck
everyone knows chocolate macadamia nuts
well this is very Californian acai and
blueberry flavored dark chocolate
so essentially dark chocolate covered
dried fruit trade look at these luscious
little babies this is so good I love mac
nuts it's all about the books chocolate
as good as it tastes healthy I love it
look at first it doesn't taste salty cuz
i just use chocolate and I think even
chewing them like what is it like
healthy flavor it's this I berries this
is so good
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah I mean like it's milk chocolate
and then convenient knots like it's just
perfect like what else you need this
makes me feel more like an adult this
this literally feels like an adult snack
so I feel like the more you have subtly
it's like oh wow like this actually it
grows on me like I like it but for like
the milk chocolate macadamia like you
just love it right off the back is
delicious
I feel like a lot of snacks I feel like
I know the flavors I know the taste I
know that you know they like to make
alternative healthier versions of things
but eating like the Hawaiian snacks just
reminded me of how much that I loved
about healthy food
I feel like hands down the Hawaiian
snacks are so much better because they
were like really tasty you could see
yourself eating the whole bag like I
could eat the rice crackers literally
like you said any time of day I could
definitely eat the box of food chocolate
macadamia nuts
any time the kool-aid strawberry sprayed
soda lucky thing that's actually pretty
good
it's a lot of sugar slam jam beef sticks
yes I would definitely eat that all the
time on any road trip or any snacks I
see it I'm like combination of healthy
or not healthy snacks but Hawaii snacks
definitely have like that little little
little ounce of the tropical magic in my
opinion like I mean I love traveling and
vacationing in Hawaii and it brought me
back to like the flavors of the way
[Music]